so much happens in 5b i want to start
with lucifer
seemingly becoming god everyone takes
the need to him
is he god well you'll just have to wait
and see okay
what i i can't tell you that i think
we're left to assume that that's
probably what's happening next in
lucifer's life i think we learned that
maybe it's not that simple
in the final season oh my me
what was your reaction when you read
that scene
in the script i'd known what was
happening for a while actually
the weird thing was when we were filming
season five for the majority of it we
thought that that was going to be our
final season because that's what we were
told
so we were writing towards the end of
the show and then
we sort of took a sharp left turn a few
weeks left in the writers room
i wasn't sure how we were going to sort
of not make it the end if you know what
i mean i was happy with what we did and
where we left it because i
feel like we left it on i always like to
leave it on an upward inflection like oh
just before we go so yeah i was happy
with that for sure
everyone deserves a second chance what
does that
mean for lucifer's journey in the final
season
well it means that lucifer's journey has
not gone full circle yet
which is what i think you know we would
have assumed it had done at this point
there's still
one part of lucifer's journey that he
hasn't banked on basically
not that he was planning this journey
out but i think he probably felt like
this was it and then all of a sudden it
isn't you'll have to watch season six to
find out what on earth i'm talking about
i have an inkling lucifer is not sure
how he was able to come back to earth
from heaven
after he gave chloe that ring what was
it about his i guess
selflessness in that moment that did
bring him back
that was his sacrifice because i think
he felt that by giving her that ring
that that would be the end of him and
they'd never see each other again i
think he thought that was it but he did
it out of love because he felt like her
journey hadn't finished and her story
wasn't meant to end this way so that's
why he gave her the ring
um and not because he thought it was
gonna it was gonna magically bring him
back
i choose you chloe
when he does give her the ring he puts
it on a very specific
finger her ring finger are we getting a
decker star
engagement or a wedding it's the only
finger that fit
i talked to joe and ildy and they told
me that it was intentional
it was very intentional i mean obviously
it's very symbolic and
i think because lucifer felt like that
would be the end of him at that moment
in time
that's why it's symbolic in that moment
because it keeps them connected for
eternity in that sense and
our audience would would never have seen
a proposal otherwise
but now that now there's a chance now
there's a chance so you're saying is a
chance
lucifer also tells chloe i love you
finally after what seems like the
longest five seasons of all time
why was that the perfect time for him to
say it
i think it's that moment of of clarity
of realization of
not knowing what you what you've got
until it's gone you know lucifer had
many many doubts about what love
actually is and what that means to him
and because he felt he'd probably never
experienced it but
i think he's realized through this whole
journey that he has experienced love and
it's the first time he's been able to
admit that to himself when he admits it
to her
i love you what does this mean for
decker star
in season six well it means that there
is a lot of decker star in season six uh
these are gonna go crazy over there i
know and there's some twists and turns
like there always isn't
in our deck of stars story lucer and
chloe are very much together in season
six so deca star lives
i feel like him not saying those three
words for a long time was a very big
obstacle for them in a way what hurdles
will they have now that they
are together and he said these words one
of the things that we thought about with
season six is that we like the notion of
like and they all lived happily ever
after
and then what happens when people live
happily ever after do they actually live
happily ever after
or is there more story there is there
more
things that they haven't experienced
that they have to experience together
now
and is that going to be a good thing for
them together or a bad thing for them
together that's where it takes us in our
story and
you know as always with lucifer there is
there's always some kind of curveball
some kind of celestial curveball
that happens and it would be wrong for
me to say that that doesn't happen in
season six
does it have to do with dennis haybert's
version of god
because he's now gone to a separate
universe
could you really ask me for all these
spoilers aren't you i'm just i'm just
i love the fact you're theorizing so
much though it might do
[Laughter]
can you tell i watched the show i did
watch all of it yeah no you do you've
really gone to school on it haven't you
is it something to do with dennis yes in
a way yes what is their relationship
like
after what has happened in five how do
you see that evolving
or uh it takes on a like
officially being together what does that
actually mean when one of you is human
when one of you is celestial and that's
where we sort of
find ourselves exploring um in season
six
now you see what i've been dealing with
shifting gears a little bit
dan sadly dies in 5b i spoke to kevin
and he said the character most affected
by his death aside from trixie is
actually lucifer so i'm wondering what
your take is
on that there's a profoundness to dan's
death that hits lucifer and you know
lucifer has spent all these years
teasing down and chastising him and
but ultimately under all of it i think
that he realizes that he deeply cares
about them
and i don't want to sort of glibly use
the word love too much but
whilst there is a romantic love going on
between lucifer and chloe there's a love
and affection that lucifer has grown
for the other characters and the other
humans in the story that he hadn't quite
counted on and so when dan dies it opens
up something elusive but it's very dark
god it's a really sad moment it really
is tell me it's not true
i can't another big storyline this
season was michael
big bad and 5b first of all for you how
was it to play both characters
kind of mentally physically it was
pretty exhausting
um but it was you know it was fun as
well it was one of those things where
when i said yes to doing it i didn't
really kind of like count on
how much i would be doing it you know i
did really enjoy the process
playing two different characters felt a
little bit like playing two
characters in a play where you run off
stage and he'd quickly change into the
other character and then you're back on
stage you're gonna do that
and that's basically what i found myself
doing especially in that family dinner
scene
in the first episode that was like two
days of filming and me just flitting
back and forth between the two
characters and that's why michael's hair
is like michael's hair because
essentially if you look at it it's
lucifer's quiff and i've just gone like
this
[Laughter]
that's so funny i can imagine though it
probably took a toll do you get
a break from playing as much michael in
season six
yes uh basically um yes
is this your answer to that i thought
this moment would give me some catharsis
i am hearing that there is a big villain
in season six
but in a way it could be lucifer with
himself
he's kind of his own worst enemy in a
lot of ways is that true
or what did he hearing his rumors from
where are you and joe told me oh they're
terrible yeah well lucifer's
as we sort of realized over the seasons
lucifer's worst enemy really is himself
so someone who is very very confident
suddenly wrecked with doubt that's part
of lucifer's obstacle there is a big
villain
that comes in in season six it's someone
that we've we've already met
is it a main character i'm not gonna say
i'm just gonna say something we've
already met okay that's a good team
for some reason i love maze so much but
i'm always worried about her whether
she's just gonna flip
yeah well that could happen as well i
think you would be more cheeky with it
if it was her
yeah i know lucifer has come so far over
the past few seasons
what is your favorite thing about his
development and his
journey from the beginning to the point
that we're at right now i think
just that the fact that he's had a
journey the fact that this character has
grown and evolved
as the seasons have gone on it's been a
different chapter and lucifer's
growing up because i feel like he
started very much as a teenager
a petulant teenager in our in our early
seasons
and certainly by season six and i'd say
by the end of season five lucifer has
really turned into a man though he
wasn't a man but he wanted to be judged
not by how he was perceived by people
and how people perceive the devil to be
he just wanted to be his own person and
be able to go and take him on face value
basically
and he's turned and evolved into that
man by the time we get to season six
now there's a ringing endorsement for my
campaign poster what more is there to
learn
about lucifer and his story in the sixth
and final season the moments that i've
really thought have resonated on this
show when we when we delved into the
family side of lucifer
when we delve into family stuff in
season six there's
something that he's never experienced
before in terms of like an emotion
or yeah in terms of an emotion and a
feeling i'll take that as he has
you guys already did shoot season six so
i'm curious what the final days were
like
it was weird i mean like knowing that we
were finishing was beneficial in that
process actually i've had such a fond
amazing time
doing this show that i was readying
myself to finish for a long time
and i guess like every day i was going
to work i was kind of as part of the
grieving process really
there's an episode towards the end of
the final season that actually was quite
a cathartic episode to shoot
and the scenes that i found myself doing
on the screen
were pretty cathartic and there's a very
sort of there's a very brutal honesty
about a lot of those scenes
my hairs are going up thinking about
actually um and so that really helped
actually it kind of was almost like i
was
was getting it out on screen and i knew
that finishing the show
meant that i wouldn't be coming to work
with those people anymore but it didn't
mean those people would no longer be in
my life
friends forever friends forever indeed
you know i really thought you'd be more
excited about this
the first time i ever interviewed you we
thought that that was the final season
and i asked you
if you were happy with how lucifer's
story wraps up but now
that we've added on so much story how
happy are you
with how lucifer's journey ends i feel
content
which is not always the case it's quite
a luxury to know that you can finish
your story properly
so that is a much more satisfying
feeling than
being cut short i feel happy i feel like
we told the story we wanted to tell you
know i love where we left it i love
what what that means at the end of it
when where we left it
after lucifer ends will you fully say
goodbye to this character
would you ever consider a spin-off or
reprise the role if the right
place for him popped up oh you look
i always say never say never it's
cleverer to do that
i think for now i'll put the horns to
bed you know i this was very much
a story like these six seasons of blues
was very much a complete story
so i'm happy to put the character to bed
for that if you know something came up
in the future
and it felt like the right thing at the
right time then of course i'll never say
never but
certainly for now this is it people well
in the meantime
how about business as usual nice little
murder take your mind off things
do you think there's another character
on the show who potentially warrants a
spin-off
trixie trixie that's actually a very
good answer
yeah why not indeed do you have a
message to the decker star fans
after they watch 5b you got what you
wanted i hope and then in season six
you're gonna get even more of what you
wanted but be careful what you wish for
how would you describe the final season
what words would you use
um oh gosh emotional
um and nuanced
but what just happened
you